mrs. Travers is a very complicated
character I mean I suspect it's it's
hard to kind of figure out where you
kind of start to get at somebody like
that worried me most was when we make
movies we watch movies we tend to watch
people being not the same everyone's got
to go on a journey you know there's
always the arc don't it anyway but that
we're used to people being morally
somehow similar from beginning to end or
they change in a very clear way and this
was not what happened to her at all she
doesn't suddenly become a nice person at
the end of the movie
she doesn't suddenly realize even that
she loves Ralph she doesn't realize that
there's that's not her thing and she's
also fantastically inconsistent so one
minute she's being violin and another
moment in this she's actually being
quite Marian or she's dancing what she's
wearing a pink caftan never a good idea
by the way um particularly with the perm
and but you know she was inconsistent
and I remember one of my early worries
was I wonder if the audience will think
that I have just got it wrong and
forgotten what she's like just suddenly
behaved in a completely different way
because I have not doing my job properly
there was that mr. Sherman you were able
to see this in real life and then
through the film itself I'm curious what
that's like to experience it both both
ways well once it was very painful and
the second time it was rather
fascinating and enjoyable which one was
which Hey
yes but you know I I kept saying to
myself as I was watching real things
that were happening done through the the
actors and through the performances and
through the script and I was saying to
myself I wish I had known this script
when I was working with mrs. Travers
fifty years ago I would have had a
little more understanding of what was
going on because I all I know is she
came and imagine this you've just taken
a very warm wonderful bath and you come
out of the bath you feel just great and
somebody comes in with ice water and
pours it on
right away Bob and I and Don dagradi had
been working for almost two years on
developing this story and we felt we
finally got it in Wharf felt we had it
and we had a whole bunch of songs and
everything we were very up and when we
first met mrs. Travers we were the
happiest guys in the world said we're
gonna meet this lady and she's gonna be
so happy and she said the first thing
out of her mouth was well I don't even
know why I'm meeting you people and
we're not gonna do a musical and you
know it was so you might say it was much
more enjoyable to second to me when you
started writing was it always in your
mind a story less about a business
negotiation than it was about letting go
and about the role that art serves and
somebody's personal life and how they
kind of relate to their own art yeah
absolutely it was always for me it was
always going to be a film about
forgiveness and the you know the effect
that our parents have on us as children
and how we carry that into our adulthood
and how do we let it go but I always
wanted it to be about catharsis and
letting things go and I feel like the
negotiation between Disney and Pamela is
actually secondary to that a lot is
known about Walt a lot is known about
this period in US history how do you
kind of embrace that and also set it
aside to kind of create the performance
that you're looking for well there's so
much video footage of Walt Disney that
it's a treasure trove the late died and
is the middle it's lovely to see that up
at the at the end of the film by the way
gave me complete total open access to
the Walt family Walt Disney Family
museum up in the Presidio in San
Francisco so I was up there twice and
one day it was closed and I just turned
everything on for me I spent hours so I
saw every piece of video and heard every
piece of audio that's on display up
there as well as had access to tons of
videos an awful lot of audio recordings
of him that the difficult part is most
of the video and audio is him performing
as Walt Disney you know hi you know here
we are in the middle of Tomorrowland you
know that kind of stuff
but and so that gives a gives you a
certain sort of cadence and a sort of
posture the way it fills out a
silhouette but getting into the more
conversational aspect of it there there
was enough there in order for me just to
find how he talks to Tommy but most of
it turned out to be fabulous anecdotal
stories and information from from
Richard and from some number of other
people who who knew him extremely well
so it was just it's just grunt work to
tell you the truth it's just you know
you just got it's like coal mining you
just you grow it very well all right
where do you where you going today I'm
going I'm gonna stir I'm gonna turn I'm
gonna put some disks in this slot and
I'm gonna start with a pen and I'm just
going to listen to as much as I can and
you it's like it's like panning for gold
we we were done a great service by being
a lot of the certain amount of time and
a certain amount of space to just be on
our own and tell the the backstory
that's reflected to time time again in
sequence and and it was kind of paradise
we were on a we were on a bluff in simi
valley overlooking just scorched earth
for miles
no telephone cables no airplanes passing
over one horse six chickens me and Ruth
Wilson a beautiful story line that was
never too far from being heart achingly
painful but at the same time never
completely took the other foot out from
the world of hope also I mean you'd I
think as an actor you always have carte
blanche because you always have choice
as to what bits of information you
choose to use and draw from and what
bits you choose to leave on the side or
let history
reevaluate a later stage outside of the
film process for me I just really had
Kelly's wonderful script and I had every
time the film goes back to Traverse and
and and Ginty and the missus and the
kids it's a very particular time in
their lives it's a very particular time
in the in the in the regression or the
disintegration of the marriage or of his
health so it was very clear I kind of
had a great understanding based on
Kelley's views for writing of where
Travers was and how he was being chopped
down both physically and emotionally by
his sadly by his own existence and all
the good fortune in the fact that he
couldn't feel any of it well I think
anytime you're going you're going back
and forth between two different time
periods
is you have to look kind of totally and
thematically at what you're leaving and
what you're coming to to make sure
there's a marriage bridge there if you
will so from a pallet standpoint
certainly we shot on film with
anamorphic lenses most specifically
because I wanted to capture the
wide-open spaces of Australia but we
also used a lot of devices you know
think thank you John Ford a lot of
framing devices every time almost every
time you see young gentie and sometimes
Piell it's through through either a
window you notice a lot of the times
when she's talking with her father she's
outside looking through a window there's
a storybook element to that visually and
it was always going to be difficult
because this was not just 1961 in 1906
you come to find in the script which was
a fantastic thing when you're reading it
all of a sudden you go wow because it's
brand-new information you don't often
see in movies where these are strands of
time that are kind of inter woven in a
way and these are memories of hers and
you get to the point where you realize
that 1961 is intruding on the memories
of 1906 even at the point that you know
this this fine gentleman's lyrics are
put in the word into the mouth of her
father giving a speech so gone by that I
must say that was an amazing piece of
cinema a cinematic magic but it thank
you Richard man but it's a but but that
adds a you know a new conundrum in a way
and so then you start to think about you
know maybe perhaps she's not completely
reliable in terms of these memories and
you start to think that childhood
memories are stylized and idealized it's
very much like Rachael Griffis when we
were talking about it and I said I want
you coming in and your feet are in first
position in the carpetbag has held the
Slee and the umbrella is like this just
like Mary Poppins and she said that
you're not looking for any reality here
and I said no a bit and I explained it
to her and she said I know what you're
talking about she said when I was a
child had an uncle that I swore was
seven feet tall and the most handsome
man in the world and then he went away
he left and then traveled the world and
came back and he was five foot nine and
a bore but in her but in her mind
looking up to him he said he filled it
he filled a doorway so there was
you know some of those kind of things
not that they're inaccurate it's just a
childlike memory does the movie that the
movies about factor into how you
prepared your actors did you show the
film before he started production was it
important that you consider it or did
you want to set it aside I mean you guys
look at the film : good call into his
graphic woodshed what was the oh you
showed it I did yeah everyone came over
and we put it on and sat outside and had
a meal first and then about three hours
into the evening everyone was getting on
so well I thought but it'll be a bit of
a bad idea to put the film on there but
I thought that was the original idea
anyway so I should follow things through
seeing as I tend not to in life it was
an easy opportunity to go against the
grain so to speak so I turned it on in
the living room and turned the volume up
and within about 20 minutes there was 20
of us in the living room sitting on the
floor and on the couch and watching Mary
Poppins and having a couple Wow that's
not good I know and how did that affect
performance or only reason one film
works obviously Tom I'm wondering as an
actor to be actually on the lot to be on
the Disney lot to be in the same offices
that Walt I don't know if you had the
exact same office or I once had an
office there a long time ago and as in
costume and everything I went in to find
my old office to discover that it had
been turned into a storage room and and
and the wall had been knocked down and
there was a leak on furan srem there and
a group of people I walked in on a group
of people and they kind of looked at me
and they said ah there you are
and I said yeah hey I'm Walt Disney now
what's what do you guys having a meeting
about potential DVD revenues and I said
I approve that was it it was it wasn't
honestly it was magically an awful lot
of people made sure they walked by where
we were shooting in order to get a look
at everything that was going on Johnny's
not Thomas Newman is not here but I want
to hear a little bit about your ideas
for music music is obviously a central
component of the story what do you seek
to do in terms of score and how that was
set apart from the film itself the music
in the film we had a lot of discussions
you know a brilliant guy and he loved
many talks with Richard but also taking
the music that was in the film that
Richard his brother wrote and then
somehow finding that family for your
theme is for your themes as well I think
was was important to him
there's Anu as an interesting thing I'm
going to give Thomas credit for this too
we did the pre records remember we were
Capitol Records and you're in there
you're recording all the voices and the
actors singing in the piano stuff and we
had 20 extra minutes after the actors
been cut loose and we had Walt Disney's
PN one of his pianos that he owned in
one of his houses and it was a rehearsal
piano one of the flat back ones so it
doesn't sound great it's a rehearsal
piano but we had it there and Randy
Kirby was he's Randy critizise named
brilliant pianist was there so we've got
20 minutes you want to do anything and I
said you know what just because I know
I'm gonna need it for a track play
Chincha Murray one note at a time as
simply and as hauntingly as you can and
so he did a couple of takes of that and
it was beautiful because it ends up
being kind of like name that tune you
hear a note and another note and then by
the time you get to the third or fourth
you go I know what that is and so it
ended up you know working for the for
the for the bookends but it was funny I
never never thought that it would
necessarily be in the movie but I got
fonder and fonder of as we kept working
on it and then I asked Tom said are you
going to keep the piano at the start in
the end and I said I said I don't know
Emily that what do you think I thought
you know if you want to put score in
there you can do it and he said I would
leave it he said I think it's perfect he
said the other thing you're going to
have a thousand people tell you to
rerecord it on a Steinway or something
and he said I hear because you hear the
mechanics of the piano you hear it in
there and he said don't please don't
take it out he said because this is the
movie that's about the creative process
and the work that goes into a finished
product because I love hearing what
business piano work hard to make these
notes well there were there was a degree
of negotiation had to go into a couple
of tricky things you know Walt Disney
died he smoked three packs a day and he
died of lung cancer it's and how do we
show that and the truth is if we had
shown Walt Disney putting a cigarette in
his mouth and lighting it and taking a
drag it would be an r-rated movie
which would have been contrary to I
think an awful lot of the spirit of the
film in the first place but then there's
ways in order we've we figured out
literally one day at the desk it says as
long as we only see you putting the
cigarette out that will rate as smoking
I said okay I get it so I just tell me
when it was literally like and action oh
hey don't let anybody see me doing this
but then we have from another of them
they're great anecdotal information we
had that was that everybody knew you
know that everybody's been to the
animation building over at Disney with
those long hallways so everybody knew
when Walt was coming to the meeting
because they would hear him clearing his
throat and coughing down by the first by
the first door and that's that's that
that's in the film so there's ways and
that you just try have to figure out
sort of like you have to game against
the system in order to get as many of
those small little details and and the
fact is he enjoyed a Scotch mist at
about five o'clock in the afternoon in a
way I'm a little bit prejudiced because
of the fact that mrs. Chavez really left
a very bad feeling with me and my
brother Bob and Don dagradi
she she did I mean she's this one over
here used to say excuse me I have to be
a [ __ ] to you now and she and she'd
play a scene and then she come back
again but in all truth mrs. Travers was
a very wounded little girl she and Kelly
brought that out beautifully
had I known truly her backstory I would
have had a lot more understanding of
everything but I used to come home just
a drenched rag I was just absolutely
destroyed everything I dreamed that the
beautiful stuff we'd written she just
pushed it aside and you know insulted us
and one day we were sitting to grotty
Bob and myself and mrs. Travers at a
lunch table and we're having lunch and
she says of course you Americans you
have no respect for dieter's so why and
she said you have no respect for exist
Winston for example never so many have
sold so much for so few and she started
quoting Winston Churchill which he
referred to him as Winston and and so
the guardian Bob
I looked at each other now and we
started saying four score and seven
years ago our fathers brought forth on
this we went through the entire
Gettysburg Address from beginning to end
and at the last thing shall not perish
from the earth
and then we just looked at her and she
said hmm
she was lovable